welcome to this video playing the
national master alexa from Israel do we
have an open Sicilian always a risky
business against against a good player
for me I mean I'm not a natural you for
player yeah I normally play their there
should be two line simply because it's a
fairly it it's one it's not a multi
reticle I know this sounds strange but
it's a line that at least can be played
without knowing so much complete theory
okay I'm trying to play for the d5
square here
maybe you can play be five anyway now
I'm just giving away your phone wow this
was like him he could just take you for
I think Jack the snow is okay hmm I have
decent control down with a position the
light on b3 I was not not well placed
this needs to be repositioned should I
play a form maybe a four is good yeah I
guess so give some some purpose here to
the rook it takes on d525 b3 is covered
under this rock before yeah look before
I thought got yacked we need something
but I can take and take these six
I think you overlooked her before yeah
he successor also no hanging it's not
just a pawn down but he's got no no
decent move okay let's see how to how to
continue yeah the f porn I mean f 2 i'm
trying to play Knight f3 and forgot
about this move Wow
hmm
can I play rugby 60 s is just insane
Bishop c5
yeah I don't see why not it looks wow
talk about unnecessary yeah well they
could have taken you for long ago so Rob
takes a 60 s damn something better rook
takes I I take Bishop takes King edge
one I don't see how I don't see a made
the night f2 is covering it and rook
takes I can really just take is as oh no
I cannot I can't take a seven okay he
doesn't have a maid and rook f6 King
edge one is also came
check yo could have played that cougar
actually no others came well 21 made
almost made it's not a direct made but
very close
ya know from they need to do that
hi i only have quincy form and now we
just moved the bishop and i'm in this
deadly pin that's also Queen f7 others
also just as Queen out to just the Queen
ah what the egg white resigns yeah I so
before good about Bishop e7 this is just
this is just dead here this position
just just any movement and it's gone I
mean I'm two pawns up for zip and pip
this one was something just not what I
did allowing Bishop e7 yeah this is just
resins for black nothing but I had I had
just blundered here for him 95 was just
far far too quickly played I need to I
need to play a normal move like this or
queen d 3 JT he allowed about everything
that you can allow and this just
blundering away the game due to look
before yeah browser simply I simply
forgot about this strange Bishop e7 move
I thought okay this is a good move of
course after that I could play this one
which I saw but I didn't I didn't see
that okay didn't see Queen III and this
is just that lost immediately alright
thanks for watching